In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 23rd, on which we commemorate the conception
of the Holy and Glorious Prophet, forerunner and Baptist, John.
On the 23rd of the month, we celebrate the conception of the Holy and illustrious
Prophet and forerunner, John the Baptist.
When our Lord and God, the only Son and Word of the Father, was about to come down from
the height of heaven, to be conceived immaculately in the womb of the Holy Mother of God.
He wished to confirm and herald this miracle of miracles by another, like to it but not
the same.
So in order that John the Baptist should in everything be Christ's forerunner, six months
before the angel Gabriel visited the Mother of God, the angel appeared to the high priest
Zacharias as he was going into the Holy of Holies to offer the sacrifice of incense.
Fear fell upon Zacharias when he saw the angel, but Gabriel reassured him, saying,
Do not be afraid, Zacharias, for your prayer is heard, and your wife Elizabeth will bear
you a son, and you shall call his name, John.
And you will have joy and gladness, and many will rejoice at his birth, for he will be great
in the sight of the Lord, and he will be filled with the Holy Spirit, even from his
mother's womb.
Zacharias and his wife were both old so that he doubted for a moment the truth of the
angel's words and that when God so wills the order of nature is overcome.
This is why Gabriel told him that he would be dumb until the birth of the child as a punishment
and to teach him to use his tongue only to give glory to God.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.